Estados Unidos y Rusia podrían volver a
la mesa de negociaciones así lo dio a
conocer al presidente ruso en el
contexto del intercambio de prisioneros
más reciente entre ambas naciones
son posibles otros cambios Sí todo es
posible Este es el resultado de
negociaciones y la búsqueda de
compromisos En este caso se encontraron
compromisos y no nos negamos a continuar
este trabajo en el futuro
sin embargo el kremlin no ve que este
paso signifique una mejora en las
relaciones con la Casa Blanca su
portavoz dimityp scoff afirmó que sería
erróneo leer los intercambios como un
acercamiento entre ambas naciones
Mientras tanto la estrella del
baloncesto estadounidense Britney ya
está en casa al momento de su llegada al
atleta fue internada en un centro médico
militar para ser revisada Víctor Wood el
otro protagonista del canje también
llegó a su país
en medio de la noche simplemente me
despertaron y me dijeron junta tus cosas
y eso fue todo no hubo información
preliminar ni siquiera sabías a dónde te
llevaban no te dijeron nada estaba Claro
que la situación se estaba desarrollando
de esta manera el la víspera
inmediatamente después de conocerse la
liberación de kriner Estados Unidos ya
marcaba el siguiente paso el secretario
de estado estadounidense Anthony blinken
ratificó la voluntad de luchar por el
regreso de otros ciudadanos de su país
detenido en Rusia el Marín Paul William
acusado de espionaje y preso desde 2018